普通のスプレーペイントでもやっちゃうんです
例えばそちらに傷跡あったら
ちゃんと何とかスプレーペイントでそれは
だからあんなごまかしはね
何のためにやるかと どこまで幻覚の嘘の中で生きていてね
嘘の哲学を喋って どこまでアホで無知で生きていきたがってるかというとわかりませんだけど
だからもう人は死んじゃったら何もしてはいけません
そのまま放っておいて見てみればどうなるかと
例えば自分の大事な人が死んだんだと
もう泣き崩れて永久的に苦しむよりは
死んだ人は日 三日間もう置いておいて見てみれば悲しみが消えちゃうでしょうね
これ大変だと なんとかしなくちゃいけないんだと
それで逆に我々は 例えば若い女の子が
娘さんが死んじゃったら
もういっぱいお化粧させて
すごい豪華な羽の衣装を着させてあげて
で もうそこで葬式やるでしょう
それでみんな見て ああかわいそうやと
とずっと 年間もなく だからもうものすごい非合理的でしょうね
いくら自分の娘が一番可愛い時
若い時亡くなっちゃって
まあそれはその瞬間ではすごいショックなんですけど
それで放っておけばどうですかと
可愛いかと かっこいいかと
どんどん膨らんで それから四日目
一週間目になっちゃうと
こっちが鼻からゾロゾロとものすごい悪臭の膿とかね
出てくるでしょうね それからどこともなく虫やらウジ虫やらあっちこっちから出てくるでしょうね
もういられません もう世の中で一番悪臭っていうのは体から出る悪臭でしょ
もう倒れちゃいます それくらいひどいんです
だからそこを事実だから見たら
あの欲とあの悲しみがきれいさっぱり心から消えるでしょうね
きれいさっぱり心が消えて
心に何の悩みも残らない
何の欲も残らないんですね
だからとにかく現代社会では無理ですけど
昔 これスリランカでもできなかったと思いますけど
インドとかは遺体捨て場っていうところがあったんですね
で 遺体捨て場だから もう人が住んでる街ではなくて
人誰も住んでない まあある場所を人は行かないところで決まって
そこに遺体を捨てると
そこでもう何キロも坊さんたちが歩いていくんです
人が捨てたと聞いたら歩いて行って
そこら辺でまあほんのちょっとずっと観察してまた帰ってくるか
だからこの瞑想っていうのはかなりもっと厳しいんです
だからこの経典の注釈書から言うと
こういう遺体捨て場に行って瞑想するお坊さんが
やっぱりまずあの長老に報告しなくちゃいけない
教会なくちゃいけないし
それからそちらへ政府やらね
そういう関係の誰かがいるんだったら
その人にも報告して 私がもうあちらに行って瞑想するんだと
ちゃんと前もって報告しなくちゃいけない
なぜかというと どこかで泥棒でもしちゃったら
家でも破っちゃったら
この人夜もう朝 朝方寺に戻るとこの人を疑われちゃうでしょうに
だから前もって言っておかなくちゃいけない
そこでまあインド昔はいろいろ悪霊の話やら信仰していたんだから
これも悪霊が出るところに行くんだからね
もう食べてはいけないものも食べ物もあるんですね
まあそれはそんなに私は信じてないんだから
まああまりどうったことはないんですけど
で まあそれぞれいろいろありますね
まあそれはまあ社会的なことで
で だから戦場が生まれるかとかないかというとね
生まれる可能性あります
第二戦場は一見なり見たら頭のある人
いつでも思考が綺麗な人にとってはすごいショックなんですね
死んでやり見た瞬間でももう自分も消えてしまっちゃって
もうもう何なの 何ですかと
この命という というすごく心がもう変わっちゃうと
欲が飛んでっちゃうんです
で そういうことがあります
でもこの 何といいますか
根性が弱くて そういうもうずるずるずるずる性格の人にはもうできません
ああ 嫌だとかね だから根性ない人にできる瞑想でもないんです
まあ今はまあほとんど無理な瞑想ですけどね
それ 10種類 でもこの骨とかね
10番目になってくると骨とかいろいろ出てきますからね
そこを骨見たっても まあこれ生きてた人でしょうと
今はこれだけやと 自分もそんなもになっちゃうんだというふうに観察すれば
まあ清らかなあすばの瞑想なんです
だからこのまあ変と書いてる 10種類もカシナと書いてる 10種類もあすばと不浄と書いてる 10種類も
見て心変わってもらう心を真理の方向へ戻ってもらう瞑想なんです
ですから この瞑想のなぜこんなことを瞑想にしているんですかと
それをちゃんと理解してもらわなくて
例えば遺体見て瞑想しましょうっていうことは
世相 今の世の中で広がっている瞑想の人々の考え方を見ればとんでもない話でしょうね
これすがすがしい 美しい神の世界体験しようという
もう欲の塊の世界でしょう
仏教ではまあそれほど単純じゃなくて
ものすごい合理的に見ているんですね
我々は人が死んじゃったらなぜ泣くかと
頭がおかしいんだから泣いてるんです
だから死んだ人を見なさいと
それは事実だから じっと見てみなさい
それで心がしっかりするんですね
それからこのヴィパッサナー瞑想とかやってると
人間っていうのはもう生きてるものだから
まあ特にこの男性 ほとんど瞑想してな男性の人々ですからね
やっぱりホルモンの関係で体はもうご飯食べてるでしょうに
で もう家を離れて もう何の欲的な生活ともしないで
一人だってだけ生活していると
もう体で欲が生まれてくるんですね
心では修行したい気持ちがあっても
心が清らかで修行したいんです
でも自分が体が元気で健康で
で それなりに適当にもご飯食べてるし
かえって食べる量減ってるんだからさらに健康的なんですね
酒飲んだり 夜 12時まで食べて食べて食べてふざけたりしちゃうと
もう疲れて疲れて元気がないでしょうし
この裁決出る場合は で
一旦出家したら もう食べる量はものすごく控えて
もう酒ももう何も体に
悪いものは取ってないんだから
もう病気ない人でもかえって元気になってしまっちゃうでしょうに
そこで体が元気になってくると
どうせこの植物ですから
体っていうのは で 欲が生まれるんですね
体から 体に変化を起こしちゃうと
その影響で心が変わるでしょう
そこで今まで自分がもう嫌だと女の人の家族も置いておいてきたんだけど
また逆に見えちゃうんですね
可愛く見えちゃうんですね
あ 心配だと そうやってまた家のことを思い出したりするでしょ
だからその場合は親切にその人々をね
育てなくちゃいけないんです
その人を悪いわけじゃないんです
例えば若い人が出家して瞑想を始めたんだと
正直な気持ちで瞑想を始めたんだけど
自分持っているこの植物は体という植物の法則で動いているんだから
だからそちらの影響でまた考え方おかしくなると
まあそれはそれで治療しなくちゃいけないんですね
仏教の治療はまあこういう
人をまあ遺体でも見てみなさいと
で見ると まあ気持ちが心が変わる
心が変わると体も落ち着いてきます
そういう風にいろいろ対症法としてある瞑想なんですね
ですから まあそのそのごれたい
かなり特殊な世界なんですね
だから出てどんな人にもいいわけでもないんですし
そこで頭の悪い人はいくら遺体にたっても禅定が生まれるわけでもないんですね
それだったらこの解剖をやっている人々やらね
葬儀屋やってる人々っていうのはもうとっくに
禅定のもう苦労でしょうね
全く逆でしょ そういう人々の世界っていうのは
だから頭がもともとおかしい場合はしょうがないんだけど
やっぱりきちんと科学的に
もう医学的ではなくて科学的に見なくちゃいけないんです
だからまあ私もそこの情報を見てみたんだから
やっぱり医学的に見ると全然汚くも何もないんです
人の骨であろうが 死因そうであろうが
腐っているものであろうが
死んでも 1ヶ月間もそこかどこかで放り出してあって
それで腐って腐って腐って
それでも医学的な目で見ると
全然別に汚くも何でもなく
研究対象だけなんですね
そこじゃなくて生きてる人でしたと
私も生きてる人でしたっていう感じで見ると随分違うんです
はい まあそんなもので
10種類の不浄というものがあります
次にアヌッサティ瞑想
これは随念と読むんですね
随念っていうのはこの念じる瞑想
このアヌッサティは随念とありますから
これサティだと錯覚してはいけません
サティではないんです
これは随念 念じるということなんです
だから瞑想は違うんです
まあちょっと言葉誤解してそれまあサティとごちゃ混ぜにしている場合もありましたからね
ごちゃ混ぜにするもんじゃない
これは全く別な瞑想なんです
随念というのは まあこれも一般的に世の中でありますし
キリスト教でもありますし
この神を念じる マリア様を念ずるとかに
阿弥陀さんを念ずるとかに
そうやって何かを念じる
南無妙法蓮華経 南無妙法蓮華経というのも
一つの言葉を念じる呪文となることも随念なんですね
そこで念ずるんだったら効果的なものを念じた方がいいんです
念ずることで集中力が生まれます
どんな言葉でもいいので
頭の中でずっと念じてみてください
なんとなく集中力が生まれてくるんです
だからといって もう何でもいいというわけじゃなくて
もっと効果的に合理的に心清らかになる
智慧が発達してくる 何か選んだ方がいいんですね
それでブッダの好きダンマの好きサンガの好きというブッダを念ずると
この遠い昔やったこの仏随念なんですね
この念仏になって変化したのは
でも念仏とは全く違う宗教なんです
同じというわけじゃない
一応そういうことに発展していっただけのことです
念仏の場合は実在する何かあって
存在があって それにすがるためにやってるんであって
こちらでは人のことを思うだけのことなんですね
今現代我々葬式でやってること
人が死んだらみんな死んだ人に喋ってくるでしょ
日本の場合は まあそれもまあどうせやってること馬鹿馬鹿しいんだから
とことんやってもいいんだけど
あの何を喋るかというと
その人のいいことをやってきたこと
思い出になったこととか
結局は自分が思い出す
それだけのことなんですね
それで人死んだ人に対して
あなたはね こういうこういうことで
よくもう素晴らしい まあまあああだこうだと
まあ意味がないんだけど
やっぱり生きている人々が
その人の人生を一つまあ考えてみる
思い出してみる まあそんなことなんですね
だから同じ働きで これブッダのことを念じてみる
いわゆるブッダのことをとことん考えてみるということなんです
ですから 本当はこの特別な言葉を選んで念じるというのもいいんだけど
私はこの智慧の方向 仏教は智慧の教えだから
この今タイなんかは有名になっているブッドウッドーとかなんとかとかね
それよりは元々の瞑想は違うんじゃないかなと
あれも現代的にやっていることだから
どうせ無知な瞑想で見えちゃうんですね
ですから 一番古いやり方は一番知識的な瞑想なの
一番古いやり方というのは
ブッドウッドー ブッドーと言うんじゃなくて
阿羅漢 阿羅漢 阿羅漢と言うんじゃなくて
阿羅漢というのはどういうものかと
そこを考えてみるんですね
やっぱり煩悩なくなった状態
束縛がない状態 清らかな心状態
人は生きる目的を達成した状態です
だから阿羅漢ですと だからブッダは阿羅漢ですよと
四聖諦のね 九十滅道のこの分かりにくい
この複雑な真理を だからそれはもう体験しているんだと
なんかすごくありがたくなっちゃうという
例えば仏教の経典なんか読んでみると
お釈迦様は堂々と話しているでしょうに
私がこれを分かれましたと
私がこういうこういう煩悩は全部なくなったと
私がもうやることは全部やって終わった
と言うと なんとなく羨ましくなるというか
すごいと いうふうな なんか心に明るさが生まれてくるんですね
やっぱりチャレンジしなくちゃいけないんだと
どれぐらい貯金のゼロが増えるかということにチャレンジするんじゃなくて
こういうことにチャレンジしなくちゃいかん
例えばお釈迦様は微かなことにも怒らなかったと言っちゃうと
羨ましいなと 私がもう風吹いたって怒ってしまっちゃいますから
やっぱりいいなとか思っちゃうでしょうに
できればとね そういう方向へブッダのことを念じればすごいもんなんです
なぜならば ブッダの性格っていうのはものすごい幅広くて
どんな側面から見てももう完璧で完璧で
もうもうどうしようもないんです
なんか一つはあるんじゃないかなと
人間だからといって何一つもないんですね
ちょっと文句言いたいところっていうのは
どこから見てもとてつもない完璧な人格なんですね
そこで私たちが考えてる完璧な人格っていうのは
なんか雲の上のような存在なんですけど
お釈迦さんそれもないんですね
その点でも完璧なんですね
雲の上に生きてるんじゃなくて
ちゃんと土の上でみんなと一緒に生きていたんですね
みんなと一緒に托鉢して
そこで道観に行ったらブッダってどちらですかと
みんな知らないんですね
それぐらい一般的で このあなた方の先生ってどちらですか？とかね
それぐらい一般的でいて
だから雲の上の存在でもなかったし
だからといってまるっきり一般人かというととんでもないんですね
この人間の中であれほど頭の良い人っていうのはもう見つかりっこはない
そこで喋るとみんなじっと聞いてるだけで
もう一つも一言ももう反論とか何もできません
そうやってどんな角度から見ても優れてることはもうものすごい桁外れです
だから道徳といったったら完璧に守っている
知恵と言えばそれまた完成してやる
そうやってお釈迦様の特色はここに座るんです
このイティピソ・ブラヴァー・アラハンというのは随念
ブス随念の瞑想の文句なんです
サンマー・サンブド・ショーガクシャーでありましたと
ヴィッジャー・チャラナ・サンパーンの智慧と道徳は完成していたんだと
だからどういうどういう知恵かと
それちゃんと書いているんです
チャラナは行はどういうどういう行で
行は優れていたんですかと
スガトーというのはもうなんだかんだうまくいったという意味で
ローカヴィドゥというのは世間でというか
世間のことだったらもう手に取ったように理解しているんだと
アヌットロ・プリシャダンマ・サーラティ
この上ない人々を指導する場合は
調教する場合はあれほどの先生がいないと
サッター・デーヴァ・マヌッサーナ
すべての生命の先生ですよと
それでブッドーとバラワーという
そういうふうな このお釈迦様のここのその性格をとことん勉強したり
考えたり 念じたりすること
だからすごく明るい瞑想です
それやっちゃうと百パーセント人が治っちゃうんです
人間の悪いところとか
なんとか性格の嫌なところとか
みるみるうちに無くなっちゃう
そこをやっちゃうと必ずしも瞑想したくなっちゃうんです
もうとにかく瞑想したくなっちゃうんですね
それであの解脱はなんとかとかね
涅槃になったらとか なんか嫌だなという感じがあるんです
やっぱり欲望の世界って楽しいでしょうと
そういうのは全部飛んじゃって
解脱はしなくちゃいけないと
すっごいこの精神的なエネルギーが生まれてくるんですね
大体そういう目的で この一般的な
これは一般的な瞑想でいいんです
変な瞑想にすることもできますけど
だから私が推薦したいのは
そうやって知識的に考える
それからいろいろ研究する
理解しようとする ブッダのことを
そうやってブッダの研究ですね
ブッダについてのちゃんとした研究理解もブス随念なんです
それやっちゃうと必ずしも人は変わっちゃう
だからこの仏教研究やってる
このカトリック教の神父さんやらこの人々も
結局自分がカトリックだ
神父だ 神父さんで 牧師さんで威張ってますけど
あれ威張ってるの殻だけ
心の生き方っていうのはやっぱりもう変わっているんですね
これも避けられないんです
すっごくケア すごいしっかりした
もう正直な人間になってしまっちゃうんです
だからこのそういう人々をいろいろ知ってるんだから
同じ世界のことだから
普通の純粋にキリスト教の神学やってる人よりは
真剣真面目に仏教学やってる人々が信頼できる神父さんなんですね
そう聞いている まあ喋ってるのはキリスト教かもしれませんだけど
やっぱりもうからくりとかね
インチキとか それは全くない
だからほとんどインチキやってますからね
もう平和の教えだという中で戦争やってるんだから
愛の教えだと言いながら人を殺しているんだから
人を助ける教えだと言いながら人をいじめているし
そういう本人がインチキやってることさえ分かってないんですね
でも仏教なんか勉強しちゃうと
やっぱり真剣真面目にやるっていうことになっちゃうんです
だから キリスト教信仰をやってもいい人になっちゃうんです
まあそうやって あの人の心は真理の方向へ行くということも避けられないんです
ブッダのことを考えること
他の誰のことを考えたとしても
そうはなりません たとえアインシュタインについて瞑想したっても
リンカーン大統領について瞑想したっても
立派な性格の人間になるということはないんですね
それで じゃあ次は法の随念
それはあの仏教を一生懸命勉強することは法随念なんですね
で 像の相の随念というのは
いろんなこの偉大 偉大なる阿羅漢たちの性格をね
生き方をね とことん観察することなんですね
そちらにはあのスワッカート・バガヴァタ・ダンモという文句は法随念の瞑想の文句
スヴァティパンノ・バガヴァト・サーガ・サンゴという文句は相随念の瞑想文句なんですね
そこら辺はとことん研究したり考えたりすること
念じただけでいうのはそんなに意味がないと思いますけどね
で 今現代 このインターネットいろいろ調べると出てくるのは
このブッドー ブッドー
ブッドー サンマーラハンとかなんとかとか
言葉ずっと繰り返すことで
それこそ瞑想だとある有名な坊さんが書いていたんだけどね
まあ勝手にしろってこれ結構あんまりなんですけど
で そうやってこの何か念じちゃうと
まあ当然心は集中力だから落ち着いてきます
落ち着いてくると 欲やら怒りやらね
余計なことは抑えてはいけます
そこでどんどん現象が
幻覚が生まれるということです
あれはややこしいんです
わざと幻覚作るのを決してややこしくじゃないんです
だからわざと何か作って
じゃあ幻覚作ってみるぞっていうのは
それは全然間違いはないんですね
はっきりしてるんだから
ブッダのことを念じてブッダが現れてくると困るんです
もしそれで本当だと思っちゃえば
でも知ってる人にとっては問題ないんです
どうせこれは瞑想の結果として出てきた幻想ですよと
単なる幻想ですよ それだけでも十分ですけど
そこまでの知識がない人がやっちゃうとちょっとわからないんですね
本当に困っちゃうんですね
そういうことを気をつけてほしい
そこで次にやるのはシーラーンセッ
戒を念じること この戒を念じるということは
この自分の今日中の生き方
観察しなさい しなさいと
で 戒律を守る場合は必ずストレス溜まっちゃうんですね
なぜならば 戒律っていうのはやりたいことをやってはいけないという法則だから
やりたくないことはやりませんというのは
戒律でもなんでもないんだからね
私はご飯は食べますけど
土は食べませんと すごい良い人
何のこともないんだからね
ですから 戒律っていうのは当然やりたいものがやらないと自分をコントロールすることが戒律なんですね
ということは必ずしもストレス溜まるんです
そこで 戒随念瞑想した方がいいんです
例えば酒を飲みたい 美味しいと
楽しいと で 飲みませんと決める
それでストレス溜まるんですね
溜まってもたまたま私はもう酒やめてもう一年ですよと
その間は一滴も飲んでない
いろんなところに行ったんだけど
いろんなパーティーに参加したんだけど
私はもうきちんと自分を決めた筋を通して守ったんだと
自分の何て言いますか
成功を念じるんです 自分にはもうちゃんとやり遂げることができましたと
そうやって自分のこの努力を評価する
それは戒随念なんですね
そこですごく心が明るくなってきて
自分のこの何て言いますか
決断力というか このもう決まったものはもうずっともうやり続ける
この忍耐力とか そういう自分に必要ないい性格がどんどんどんどんついてきますね
そこでどうなるかというと
戒律から出てくるストレスは全部消えちゃうんです
例えば 私は年間も酒飲んだことはないんだと
もうやめろと決めた時から
それで飲みたいな飲みたて一年目では思いませんね
何のことなく 今さらと何だとという気持ちになっちゃうんです
ですから 戒律に対してストレスも消えちゃって
すごいしっかりした人になっちゃうんですね
だから悪いことは何のことなく避けられる
いいことだったらしっかりできるような人になるんですね
そういうことの瞑想なんです
戒随念 これやらなかったら結構苦労するんです
それ何です？俺は瞑想していますから
これはやっぱりお坊さんたちの世界なんでしょう
お寺の瞑想の世界っていうのは
だからすごい戒律いっぱいありまして
これ死ぬほど自殺したくなるほどうるさいんです
戒律の世界でも誰一人も自殺したことはないんです
戒律うるさいのに だからまあそこそこ適当に戒随念の瞑想で
その精神的な問題はちゃんと解決しているんです
だから この修行している在家の方々を見ても
たとえお金がなくても
たとえ貧乏であろうと
あるおばあちゃん おばあちゃんが死ぬ時は行ったんだけど
全く一人で 家からも離れて
小さななんか葉っぱで何か屋根ちょっと作って
ほんのちょっとのところを作って
そこで寝るだけのところ
なんかもうホームレスみたいな感じなんです
だからあの自分の子供たちやらね
もう心配させて でも来ないんだと
それ腹が立って家出て来ているんですか？と
そうでもないんですね
そこで私が行くんだから
このおばあちゃんをね
また家に戻しちゃおうかとかいう話が出ても
いいですよ 私はおばあちゃんのとこに行きますから
いいです あっちお坊さん行ったって座るとこも何もないんだからいいやと思って
行ってまあ降りて それじゃあおばあちゃんすごい明るく元気で
ただ束縛捨ててるだけなんですね
もう家もあなた方の家であって
私のもんじゃないんだから
もう勝手にやりなさいと
言って もう自分がもうずっともういろいろ修行したり
瞑想したり 戒律を守ったり
いいことをしたりして
まあ人生はもう人間としてすごくいいことをして生きてきたんだと
もう今何も要りませんと
もう死ぬ瞬間まで待ってるしかないんだと
死んだっても 自分がもういいところに行くだろうという
すごい自信があって もう死ぬ時でももう明るいんですね
うるさいほど私に説法するんです
私が説法しに行ったんだけど
だからそこはなんで本当に貧しくてね
苦労して で 最後だからちょっと甘えてもらったって構いませんだけど
そこもないんですね いらんという感じで
だからすごく立派に仏教から育てられてるんです
だからこの心 これは皆様には読めないかもしれません
この外を見ると心を見なくちゃいけないんで
人の服装ではなくて 体ではなくて心を見ると
まあすごいもう人格者なんですね
ですから このカイズネーンというのは
まあそうやって最期の人々でも
それぞれなりに使うと結構人格者になるんです
次にあるのはチャーガーのセピ
チャーガーのセティっていうのは
まあ人を助けたことやらね
まあお布施したことやらね
まあそういうことをよく考えてみることなんですね
そこで欲がなくなっちゃうんです
自分が今までいろんなことをあげてきたでしょうに
いいことをしてきたでしょうに
そこは一般の人は人に何かお金なんかでもあげちゃったら
このもらった人から一生懸命褒めて欲しがっちゃうんです
報告宣伝して欲しがっちゃうんです
それで仏教的な道徳にならないんです
あ 気持ちよかったと でもそれは悪いと言ってるわけじゃなくて
まあその人を褒めたっても
それを褒めてもらったら嬉しがったというのは
それはそれで構いませんだけど
やっぱりその目的で嬉しくなるためにみんなに褒めてもらってやっちゃうって欲なんですね
ですから 自分が一人でいろいろいいことをいろんな人にやってきましたと
そこを自分で観察するんです
私はこういうふうにいいことをして
私はこういうふうに人を助けたと
私はこういうこういうことをしてきました
そうやって自分で充実感のある人生だと
それほど悔しい生き方じゃないんだと
いろんないいことをできたんだと観察するための瞑想
だから人生にして充実感が生まれてくる
後悔が消えちゃう 虚しさが消えちゃうんです
それで欲を捨てたことを観察すると
開けたことによってこれぐらい楽しみがあるんだからと
やっぱり執着したら逆にすごい苦しみがあるんだっていうことをわかってきて
執着捨てる方向へ心が行っちゃいます
その瞑想はそこまで 次の瞑想はなんですかって？デーヴァータヌッスティ
デーヴァータヌッスティというのは神々の随念すること
でもそこで仏教とこれちょっと仏教の神々の随念は違うんです
マリア様を随念するとか
イエス様随念するとか
不動さんを随念するとかはないんです
阿弥陀さんか観音さんとかね
そういう人 誰か誰か個人を随念するんじゃないんで
そこは仏教でも禁止と
ダメ 個人を随念するんだったらブッダを随念する
ここでどういうことかというと
この どんな宗教なるものじゃないんです
ここで仏教の神の随念というのは
この生命を大きく見ると
生命にはいろいろ次元があるんだと
我々は人間の次元にいる
地獄やらいろんな生命の次元
多次元的な存在だと そこで人間より上の次元で我々より物事を見れる神々という次元があるんだと
その生命体には私たち考えることやらやってることは明確に見られているんだと
例えば私たちは心 体で隠してるでしょうに
ですから 人間同士では何考えてるかわかりません
心隠してますけど 例えば神々だったら体がないんだから
心だけの波動だったら我々の心はきちんと見えるはずなんですね
体は壁にならないんですね
そうすると私たちは何考えてるかと何やってるかっていうことは全部もうバレっぱなしだと
これ一人二人じゃなくて
ものすごい生命体に だからそこで何がなくなるかというと
偽善がなくなっちゃうんです
人間は騙されますけどね
私は一度も嘘をついたことがないんだと
じゃあ言ったことあったら証明出しなさいと言えますけどね
自分が本当に自分の心で嘘をついたことあるんだから
これ神々にはもうその瞬間にバレてるんだ
だから隠れてでも悪いことしちゃったらもう知られちゃうんですと
ということで 神々は自分の見張り役にするんです
自分の身悔の行動をコントロールするために
それには神々は実際にいるんだということをなければできません
幻覚だけでいるだろう
いわゆる仮定してはできません
ですから 神々の瞑想をするのは
本当に神々がいるんだと思ってる人々なんです
ですから 本当に神々がいるんだと思ってる人々が
人間より次元の高いレベルの生命がいるんだと思ってる人々にとっては
これはすごくいい瞑想なんです
いるんだったら 自分隠れてやってることも
隠れて考えてることでも全部バレてるんだから
ですから やっぱり自分が見られているんだ
しっかりしなくちゃっていうことで
心はしっかりしてくっぱになんない
だからそこは仏教において神の随念です
きちんと理解しておかないと
なんか私の話は本当かと思うけど
それは本当なんです 観音様に念じることは決して神のこの瞑想には入りません
シヴァ神をね おおーナマシヴァーイと言って念じるでしょ
あれはこれとは違います
あれは救いを求めてやってるんだから
それからもうハーレーラーマハーレークリシュナと歌ってるでしょうに
あれのラーマという神を念じてることなんですけど
でもこれとは違います
なぜならばそこで救いを求めているんですね
こちらでは救いを求めてるわけじゃなくて
自分の身悔の行動をコントロールするために見張り役を頼んでるだけ
えーと 次の瞑想はウパサマーヌッスティという瞑想で
何でしたっけ 寂静随念
寂静随念という これすごい
難しい瞑想ですけどね
だから一般的には理解できるところだけ言います
専門的にはもうちょっと瞑想は違いますけどね